here if you please the fourth book will
begin the country of the Danes as one
also reads in the Gesta of st. Aidan
scar is almost all spread out over
islands now this Danish land is
separated from our node Albin Jian's
by the river ida which rises in the
densely wooded highlands of the pagans
called is hanno which they say extends
along the barbarian ocean as far as the
sh lysine the ida flows into the frisian
ocean which the romans in thy writings
called the british ocean the principal
part of denmark called Jutland extends
lengthwise from the ida river toward the
north it is a journey of three days if
you turn a site in the direction of the
island of fin but if you measure the
distance direct from Schleswig to all
burg it is a matter of five to seven
days travel that is the highway of the
Caesar Otto unto the Father most see at
Vendela which sees to this day called
the ah ting sound from the Kings victory
at the Eider Jutland is fairly wide but
thereafter it narrows little by little
like a tongue to the point called
Vendela where Jutland comes to an end
thence it is a very short passage to
Norway the soil in Jutland is sterile
except for places close to a river
nearly everything looks like a desert
his salt gland and a vast wilderness
furthermore if Germany as a whole is
frightful for its densely wooded
Highlands Jutland itself is more
frightful in other respects the land is
avoided because of the scarcity of crops
in the sea because it is infested by
pirates hardly a cultivated spot is to
be found anywhere scarcely a place fit
for human habitation but wherever there
is
of the sea it has very large cities this
region the Caesar Otto at one time
subjected to tribute and divided into
three bishoprics once he established its
leche fig which also is called hey Derby
and is situated on the arm of the
Barbarian sea named by the inhabitants
the SH lie whence also the city derives
its name from this port ships usually
proceed to Slavia or to Sweden or to Sam
land even to Greece
the second bishopric he found the tribe
a city encompassed by another waterway
that flows in from the ocean and over
which one sales for frisia for england
or for our saxony the third bishopric he
planned to fix it Oz separated from Finn
by a very narrow channel that reaches in
from the east and sea and extends in a
long winding course between Finn and
Jutland northward up to this city of
ours then one sails to Finn was Zealand
or Scania or even to Norway now the
archbishop consecrated from among his
own clerics Rudolf for Schleswig Wilhelm
for Zealand Engelbert for Finn the
latter a convert from piracy is said to
have been the first to find the island
helgeland which lies hidden in a deep
recess of the ocean in the mouth of the
Elbe River and having built a monastery
there to have made it habitable the
island lies across from had elm it is
barely eight miles long by four miles
wide and its people use straw and the
wreckage of ships for fuel
rapport has it that whenever pirates
plunder their be the booty
ever-so-slight they never returned home
unpunished either perishing soon after
in shipwreck or getting killed by
someone for this reason they are
accustomed with the great devotion to
offer the Hermits who live there tithe
of their booty this island produces
crops in the greatest abundance and is
an exceedingly rich foster-mother for
birds and cattle on there is but one
hill and not a single tree it is hemmed
in on all sides by very precipitous
crags that prohibit access except in one
place where also the water is sweet all
sailors hold the place in awe especially
however pirates
hence it got the name by which it is
called high league land now held the
land from the Vita of Saint Villa broad
we learned that it was called Fawcett is
land and that it is situated on the
boundary between the Danes and the
frizziness
there also are many other islands of
Frisia and denmark but none of them is
noteworthy
Finn is a fairly important Island lying
back of that called vanilla in the
entrance of the barbarian Gulf it is
close to the region named Jutland from
every part of which the passage to Finn
is very short there is the great city of
Oden say small islands encircle it all
abounding in crops and it is to be
observed that if you pass through
Jutland into finn your route is a
straight way to the north but your
course faces east in going through finn
into zealand there are two passages to
zealand one from Finn the other from our
host each place is an equal distance
from zealand the sea is naturally
tempestuous and full of two kinds of
danger so that even if you have a fair
wind
you can hardly escape the hands of
pirates
[Music]